wall street democrats that are aligned
with years of protecting corporate
interest
over people's interests that has been
cuomo's ideology
for as long as we know another two weeks
goes by
and we are seeing mistake after mistake
after mistake and it all culminated
in a very deadly executive order
that he ordered his people ordered to
suppress the data
does the future look bright or does the
future look scary
as long as we have collaborative
politicians who can see the world as a
win-win
republicans democrats concerned we all
have the same goal which is
to reward hard work that's all we want
like we want people to feel
understand that if they put in the time
and effort that
they have upward mobility public
servants should create a world of
win-win where
it's not winner-take-all economics and
as long as we can find that balance
i do feel very optimistic we can get to
a better place very soon
[Music]
my guest today is ron kim he is new york
state assembly representing the 40th
district since november of 2012 and
recently if you if you turn on the tv if
you're watching videos you have seen his
face you have seen his name
on the view all over the place because
of a uh
controversy that came out on a call
that he and andrew cuomo governor andrew
cuomo had that's led to a lot of
different
uh issues being brought up so with that
being said ron kim thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
thank you patrick thank you for the
invite of having me on your show
yes i'm i've been looking forward to
this so you know let's get right into it
you know
you're seeing uh uh andrew cuomo one
minute we're watching him on a daily
basis every day i turn on the tv i see
his face more than trump during covet
the live conferences that was taking
place he would address the questions
he won an emmy for it then you would see
the back and forth with him and his
brother you almost thought maybe
one day there would be a tv show the
cuomo brothers you know that would be
watching
and the talks came about him handling
coronavirus better than donald trump
president donald trump at the time
and then talks came about him
potentially running for office
in the future for being a president a
democratic candidate and then
there came the the fall the controversy
that came out
how how did this lead to what it is
today
well for a long time
uh while angel como was making the
national circus and
he forgot he also wrote a book on kobe
leadership at the same time
many of us including the families who
were losing their last loved ones
lawmakers community activists we were on
the ground
seeing the impact of his bad decisions
and policies
so while he was in cnn we were crying on
the floor
on the ground saying hey your decisions
are
completely isolating our older adults
you're not
doing your job you are not allowing us
to see our loved ones
uh we can't get their medical records
you're giving a corporate legal shield
for your top nursing home executives at
the worst time
which will lead to more deaths these are
the type of things we kept pushing
up we didn't have a platform he is
arguably at the time one of the most
powerful
if not one of the most powerful democrat
in in
america with the brother as you said
patrick
who's on national tv every single night
so yes many of us did feel we're getting
gaslit
right because we see the truth we turn
on tv and they're telling us a whole
different narrative that he is a hero
when we knew that he was making mistakes
we were trying to hold him accountable
every step of the way when did you guys
know that these
events were taking place meaning was
there ever a
because you know before crisis takes
place you kind of see somebody leading
towards potential trends you say
that's not looking right when did you
guys start noticing trends
yeah so i'll go back to the timeline
when the governor
and his top health official came to us
early march this is
after colby landed in new york city and
people were starting to get scared
he asked for us an emergency 40 million
dollars
and extraordinary powers many of my
progressive democrats
they were like no we can't trust this
guy don't give him any more powers
i actually sponsored that i was the main
co-sponsor
and argued against the democrats my
constituents are scared
i don't think washington's washington is
going to help us in this hour
so let's give let's get behind this
governor let's give him a chance to lead
and then a week goes by and then a two
weeks goes by
and we are seeing mistake after mistake
after mistake and it all culminated
in a very deadly executive order with a
unilateral decision
on march 25th which he ordered
which is an order where he ordered 9 000
covet patients in the period of 47 days
back to unprepared nursing home
facilities
march 25th come april 2nd into our state
budget
when no one was paying attention when
he knew the lawmakers were looking at
other other
laws and budget items he bullied a
toxic poison bill that would give the
same facilities what we call get out of
jail free card
they can't be criminally liable or can't
be sued
for taking in all this corporate
positives and transmitting
corvette we saw it we called him out and
that's when we started a pushback
so it's okay you know what you you might
have made a mistake governor
we understand you're talking to suspect
you know these all these special
interest groups and people
who have only their businesses in mind
but this is not about protecting the
profits right now people are dying
and we need to hold them accountable to
make sure that these for-profit nursing
homes
are spending every dollar that they have
to try to save lives
you're not doing that so we kept pushing
back and all of a sudden patrick the
numbers
went away he publishes a report in july
that decoupled the nursing home death
numbers
meaning he stopped counting uh
health care experts told him you need to
count the hospital debts
so if if my mother passed away in a
nursing home
but she was transferred to a hospital
and she died in a hospital
that fatality should be part of the
entire data set so we can take
lawmakers can take a look at and offer
solutions he decoupled it and published
a report
and all of a sudden he goes out and says
new york isn't that bad
we're number 40 in the country i'm
actually going
to write a book about kobe leadership
and he publishes it in october
all that time period we're pushing back
release
the entire data so we can legislate so
we can actually
fix the problems that you caused that is
the timeline
and in all and as you know it blew up
recently because
his administration admitted to the
cover-up
in a private meeting and then the new
york times wall street journal came out
recently so there was even more cover up
leading back to their original report
in july that they preached that he
ordered his people ordered
to suppress the data so he could go out
on national tv and continue to be heroic
at a time
when we needed honesty transparency and
accountability
to save people's lives now what uh what
could have been different so if we would
have come out what would have been the
right approach to taking a
situation like this well the the laws
that we're passing now
we just we we just passed about 19
bills having all the data in front of us
which is hold the nursing homes
accountable
mandate especially the for-profit ones
so
in new york states about 63 of nursing
home facilities are for-profits
um the rest are state-owned state-run or
non-profit organizations
got it but for-profits has had a long
history
of undercutting staff cutting corners
to maximize profits as you can imagine
um
so we wanted to hold we could have held
them accountable we could have said
well for example you're getting a
hundred dollars today of medicare
medicaid out of the hundred dollars
we're going to direct you to spend 80 of
that
in direct care which is the right
standard during an emergency
but they were spending you know on
average
25 30 on direct care
meaning not hiring enough staff not
putting
enough ppe in place all those things we
could have
mandated early on but instead the
governor went the other direction
and decided to give the corporate um
shareholders and people behind the
businesses
a a more or less a blanket corporate
immunity
so they don't need to worry about
getting sued or being criminally
charged so so ron now today after the 19
bills have been passed
if i'm running a nursing home today 60
plus percent of nursing homes are
for-profit
the other 30-some percent are non-profit
if i'm running a for-profit
i have to spend 80 on direct care now so
meaning i'm
only keeping 20 of the money that's
coming to me is that what i'm
is that what the law states today or not
yet so that bill is still being
negotiated that particular bill we're
starting at 70 percent
and then over the next couple couple of
years we're trying to get up to 90
percent
of direct care i mean that's gonna
that's gonna also force a lot of people
out of the business right it's not gonna
force a lot of people out and they're
gonna say you know what ron you're right
i'm just
i can't run margins on 10 i'm i'm out of
the business myself
sure patrick and those are tough and
uncomfortable conversations to be had
should prof should for-profit models
intersect
with the care sector especially dealing
with the elderly population
is that the best model when when the
business model itself
is designed to extract as much profit on
medicare medicaid instruments or
do we need better uh mechanisms you know
my dad my dad was uh
when he had he's had 13 heart attacks my
dad when he went to uh
a uh hospital and it was a
government-funded hospital in norwalk
california
and when i went to pick them up they
were just treating them like it was just
a piece of meat you know laying there
and i lost it and they kicked me out
security came
you need to leave this place and the
lady made a very interesting comment at
the end
i said my dad's been pressing a button
no one's going over there to take care
of them
what is this all about and she said
listen you're not paying for this this
is taxpayer money
okay and i was 23 years that's one of
the motivations but it made me want to
get to work and make the money because i
never wanted to hear that statement
to have the choice for profit because my
experience has been
the customer service for profit is a
million times better than a non-profit
if i go to dmv
in la and i'll let you say go to dmv in
glen oaks in burbank
which i've been to many times for the
driving record that i have i kind of
have a reason to go there
quite often when i would go there and
they would talk to you like stand over
there
wait in line then i tell you to stand
over there i'm like oh my gosh they
didn't talk to me like this in the
military
and they don't care about yelp they
don't care about the
you know customer service they don't
care about hey can you write a five-star
review on yelp for us because it could
be we would so much appreciate it no
one's getting fired because it's
a non-profit and so for me sometimes
pushing corporations out can also
backfire on the city and not only the
city the people because competition
is a healthy thing so that's that's a
completely different conversation when
you said ninety percent
it kind of triggered the business side
of mine keep in mind when donald trump
got colbert he didn't go to a for-profit
hospital he went to a government-run
hospital
um when we talked about i know and i
know and i read and i'm familiar with
your background i respect
um as an immigrant or how what you
overcame
as an entrepreneur and really was driven
i have so much respect for your
background patrick
um but i think we live in a generation i
think we're about to say i'm 41 years
old
um and i came in an era
where private capital was unleashed in
the 1980s after ronald reagan
we went in a different way before that
you know we had a tight grip
on checking monopolies and making sure
that the smaller local economies had a
fair share
and the tax rates are much different
before ronald reagan
this is all stuff that you're familiar
with but we made a conscious choice to
go a different direction meaning
we should we surgically undermine the
public sector
every other year on the resource
underfunded
different different components where and
localities
sold off public services in piecemeal
over the last 40 years backing your
your argument that you know
market-driven solutions uh
accountability customer driven is a
better model for public service
but every if you look at the long
history of when we achieve the
greatest level of entrepreneurs
innovation is when we
government actually invested in public
capital
and we were able whether we if you look
at apple
siri would not have come if we did not
have
sputnik when we had massive capital
public capital investment to drive
innovation
and out of that may come different types
of private markets
um but i believe there is a stronger
role for the public sector
uh to reinvest
without completely you know being
combative
with the work that you've accomplished
and other entrepreneurs in the private
sector but right now
i think the balance has is is way off
uh in favoring uh the for-profit
industries in spaces like care work
when we should be investing public
dollars but
this is that we can we can have a whole
different
uh back and forth and i appreciate this
type of discussion because i do
i do have a tremendous amount of respect
uh for your expertise
um i mean in this topic i don't want to
go detail on 90
the only thing is when i think about a
small business and you're not uh
there is no incentive for it you're just
pushing a guy out and he's like listen
the hell with this i'm just leaving a
business model
and i'm going to go to a different place
but we'll come back to this because i do
want to come back to amazon
and i know you were one of the first
that uh uh talked about amazon when they
were coming down
you know in the 25 000 jobs at 150. but
let's let's stay on the cuomo issue here
um you know
it almost seems like what's happening to
the republican party is happening to the
democratic party and let me kind of
paint this picture to you and
you told me if you agree with this or
not on the republican party
you know you saw uh uh what do you call
it you saw
uh trump's going and running and you
know there was a camp i was like oh my
gosh if i support him i may what if the
midterms and what if i'm not gonna get
people in the media they're going to say
i'm mega and i'm going to get this and
this and that and so
so then they came lincoln uh project
right so the lincoln project the mccains
the bushes you know
that area and they came out and they
they play a very
very maybe more of a big role than
anybody else did
in making sure trump doesn't get
reelected the lincoln project did
and then there was division there right
so then now you have mega and you got
old republican new republican that's
kind of what's going on over there
still got 75 million votes but not
enough 74 million what's not enough to
get elected
on the democratic side you're seeing
also two camps
you're seeing the pelosi camp you're
seeing
uh you know the newsome camp you're
schumer camp and then you're seeing aoc
camp you're seeing sanders camp there's
also like two camps
i will give credit to democrats they are
10 times more united than
republicans are i mean it's not even
close how much more democrats are united
than republicans are they're not even in
the same league
democrats will at least say we may
disagree but look in front of the camera
let's all be on the same page and then
let's fight it up behind closed doors
and figure
something out here are you seeing like a
division taking place in the democratic
party today with two different
philosophies one
more you know the new wave of socialism
raising taxes higher regulation and the
other one is more like
john f kennedy democrats was like listen
guys let's still
stay understand we need wall street's
money because we're raising money and
we're doing all this stuff so we can't
just turn our backs again against them
what are you noticing happening down the
democratic party
yeah i mean that dynamics has gone
back many many years in america where at
some point
the republicans are representing the
working class values and then the
democrats
but what's clear is that new york
democrat and wall street democrats
has had a long history of creating
tensions between the rest of america
and what llc did say a couple years ago
does resonate with me which is this is
this should not be about left versus
right
but for the bottom versus the top and
when we look at the fight around nursing
home protecting these
most vulnerable members of nursing home
residents
when you look at the people who are with
me and with us
in pushing back against cuomo it's a
combination of
conservative republicans from the right
and socialists on the left and
progressives on the left
the people that are missing in this
fight have been the people who are stuck
in the middle
um the the establishment if you will
uh the corporate driven democrats or
wall street democrats that
are aligned with years
of protecting corporate interest over
uh people's interests um that is that
has been
cuomo's ideology for as long as we know
you know we
we call it uh neoliberalism and the uh
corporate democrats you know there's
different ways to describe it
um but it culminates again in
austerity-minded budgets where we're
constantly either flatlining social
programs
for decades while we subsidize as you
mentioned you mentioned amazon
briefly we think the bigger better
corporations are best
at bringing in new jobs and creating
innovation so we try to subsidize
through taxpayers tax credits as much of
that and
those type of industries to come in to
fuel uh
economic growth that's been the
philosophy of cuomo
uh and many of the the middle grounded
democrats that are in line with them
so it's not necessary tensions um
there's internal
i think uh differences of
how some of the next generation of
democrats
want to lead uh the party into
prioritizing the needs of
our most vulnerable and center the
solutions around
people's needs in the ground and we're
not talking about any
complicated things we're talking about
housing education healthcare basic human
needs that must be met um otherwise
we what we end up doing is
individualizing
everything and saying you're not you're
not successful
because you're not working hard enough
and you're it's a character flaw
and we're just going to throw carrots
and mostly sticks
with over policing and we're going to
we're going to fund more police to go
into the neighborhood
and teach you some character i mean
that's really how
many of our moderate corporate democrats
get their hands off of the situation
because it is very difficult
to go back and say we're going to
improve the social conditions
i'm sorry hi hazel how you doing baby
thank you sorry
can you close the door baby thank you
sorry about that
it's a beautiful daughter you got there
hazel but go ahead you were sane
so yeah so i believe
uh that there is a philosophical
uh divide that's brewing in the party
but it's not an unhealthy one it's a
necessary one
that i think both parties um should be
having moving forward
yeah it's it's to me it's my dad told me
he said one thing about america you
gotta know pat he says uh
you know it's very america's very good
at taking you from zero to hero
overnight you're just like everybody
knows you but america is also very good
at taking you from
hero to zero overnight you know one
minute you're winning emmys and you're
just better than trump and you're going
at it with trump and yay
cuomo go bully the bully and then next
minute no no we got to take this guy out
and uh you know now he's uh
unfortunately
you know uh going through whether it's
impeachment or being asked to resign
i've seen all the interviews whether
you've done with uh
cnn or uh uh hill i've seen all of them
what you said and with the phone call
that happened with you and him
so have had you spent a lot of time
talking to uh governor cuomo before
the call that you had where he was
threatening you was there like regular
conversations you had with them over the
phone or was that like the first call
you ever had with them this was the
first call
oh i got it okay i got it obviously i
spent time with them i got it social
events even had dinner with them
with other lawmakers etc but
yeah he this is the first time he made
an effort to call me
followed by a number of phone calls on
that saturday
a total of eight times uh to reach out
to me so this is really a reflection of
the length that he was willing to go
himself to try to control
the situation in fear that there will be
more investigations
into the nursing home scandal got it so
it's not like you guys had a
relationship and an ongoing thing going
on and then
you know you guys were talking regularly
and one day he's just threatening and
telling if you do this i'm gonna fire
you i'm gonna
you know make sure i get rid of you okay
so uh at this point of the game i think
you're
based on what i'm hearing uh when i'm
hearing different folks talk about it
you guys are hoping
he resigns rather than you go for
impeachment
there yeah every day they're more
there's a
the more growing calls from lawmakers
for him to step down so we can
refocus on do you think he will
do you think he will i don't think he
will
but as we have more people calling for
resignation the next
logical step if he does not step down is
to go through an impeachment process
uh there's only been one impeachment in
the city in new york and the second
attempt
uh through the former governor elias
spitzer led for him
to resign because i don't think any
governor wants to go through that
process
makes sense okay so the other question i
have for you is have you studied what
happened with detroit
have you looked at what happened with
detroit historically with uh
what led to detroit's demise in terms of
the bankruptcy the city going bankrupt
and yeah i mean in terms of being the
richest city in the world per capita to
not be in the poorest city in america
well i know generally uh what happened
uh but yeah if you want to
indulge me in some of the history yeah
i'm just curious because you know if we
go back
uh you know in 1950s you know you're not
talking uh 200 years ago 1950s was only
70 years ago
detroit is the richest city in america
their population went from
200 000 to 1.8 million and they had 200
manufacturing jobs where you're talking
about
you know motown came from there you're
michael jackson marvin gaye the manager
those who represented them diana ross
all these guys
and then ford chrysler you know all of
that and then next thing you know new
york city
started the uh detroit started getting a
lot of politicians were started saying
it's not fair they're making too much
money why are we giving them so many
things while we're giving them so many
tax benefits
and then they bullied these automakers
out and it went from having 200 000 uh
manufacturing jobs all the way down to
000 manufacturing jobs where jobs were
lost in a manufacturing sector
tremendously but
the municipality jobs increased meaning
more government employees
for the city and fewer private jobs and
then today
you know not only is detroit known as
the poorest city in america but
detroit's also seen as
the number one most dangerous city in
america based on the amount of crimes
that happened in 2019 the statistics are
up there to see
and i bring this up because my favorite
city in the world that i like to visit
is the one you're in i love new york
city there's something very magical and
special about new york city
and not only the city ron there's
something different about doing business
with people
in new york there's an attitude about
them there's a swagger about them there
is an
element of if i don't like you i'll tell
you it's the only city where i would go
as a 20 year old
you know when i got out of the army 21
year old if i went to nightclubs girls
flirt with guys not the other way around
it's like it's if they like you they
come up to everywhere else you kind of
have to like go but over there like hey
like i've never seen nothing like this
before you know it's a very
different swagger the city has but then
we're seeing the similar trends
happening today in new york city i'm in
florida right now i left california to
go to texas for obvious reasons
what was going on with california and i
was in texas for a while beautiful state
great state great for business they
leave you alone they allow you to do
what you're doing and i moved to florida
but now in florida you're talking about
goldman sachs
you're talking about all of these
companies coming here both from silicon
valley in new york city
you're talking about 330 billion dollars
of wealth
that left new york city that's a lot of
wealth that left new york city wall
street journal just did an article
saying
the those who left new york city the
jobs are not coming back
it's not like they're coming back to new
york city they left to other places they
left to other
states to build their businesses do you
think
the way new york's going right now with
so many new regulations and bullying
businesses to leave
new york city could potentially be the
next detroit
first well i think there's i think
there's you're conflating a couple of
different things in my opinion
sure i think the the model of putting
states against each other
and engaging in a race to the bottom
never results in a positive state even
for florida i believe it's a short term
can you unpack that can you unpack what
you yeah so when
when cities and states are competing
with taxpayers money to trying to
extrinsically
motivate companies to come to their
states
we engage in an economic uh
cage war and we're competing uh to go
down
rail race to the bottom uh at the
expense of taxpayers
uh detroit is a for me a model
an example of when we are constantly
trying to
externally motivate big corporations
multinationals to come in
and do business it's not a sustainable
approach
that's not a sustainable opinion to be
clear they did not stop
subsidizing they did continue to offer
breaks
over the years they did and and the
manufacturing companies did get
massive bailouts by washington
in the subsequent years of when the
companies couldn't compete
uh with some of the other manufacturing
companies from japan and on germany
other
global marketing companies that came
into the space
how so if we are constantly
pushing the federal reserve
to create new money and bailouts and
lending mechanisms
to bail out these corporations and push
the states to engage
in a race to the bottom it's the public
sector that will all
ultimately be at be at harm for new york
state
it's different than detroit detroit was
never the number one
uh michigan was never the number one
state in terms of economic
uh power in america new york has always
been
the number one state one point right now
we have a 1.8 trillion
state gdp uh we have our we are not
suffering economically
we as a compared to other nations we are
actually richer
uh than finland then canada as a state
of new york
we have we still have wealth sure
goldman wants to take
one component of their sector to florida
to engage us you know in a perpetual
discussion about well what can we offer
you to stay
what i'm arguing is that the more we
engage in that conversation we are only
attracting
partners who are extrinsically motivated
to do business
whereas we can be grooming companies who
are
intrinsically driven to be part of our
growth and that's what's been missing
over the last 40 years
now i know you're shaking your head but
yeah the only reason is because because
of one thing
you know you and i are both immigrants
we're the same age we're year apart so
we're pretty much just except you look
like you're 15 years younger than me i
look like i'm 20 years older than you
that's the only there you look like
you're 22. i look like i'm
52. but uh uh you know we came here
for the f word if you think about it we
came here for
the not the four letter award we came
here for freedom uh
free enterprise freedom of speech
freedom assembly freedom of
you know religion freedom of all of that
stuff right
and you know i think the one thing
that's going away in new york
is that incentive it's like it's
incentive is almost seen as a bad thing
for
businesses and corporations don't you
agree
incentives to drive people to stay here
is
no just incentive like what is my
incentive of wanting to build a business
there should be an incentive like what
is my incentive
wanting to uh create commerce or
jobs there should be an incentive yeah i
mean i i i appreciate this conversation
because you and i
uh came to this country around the same
time as immigrants
and you you took a very corporate
approach and i took a public sector
approach
sure um and the reason why i took the
public sector approach
is actually very aligned with some of
the uh the drivers that you've had as an
entrepreneur you know i came here my
parents were small grocery store owners
in in upper manhattan each day it was
like a five people
24 7 korean grocer you know a typical
experience of so many korean immigrants
that came here they shut that down
in about 10 years since we arrived here
and they would they have to they were in
financial debt for years
um and when i go back to that very pain
that grocery store that used to exist
there was there used to be six mom and
pop stores on that block
right now there's a chase bank and a
giant retail supermarket that's at two
stores they replaced
all the mom and pops so my journey of
where i am now
is trying to connect this dots um how do
what do we do wrong where the
troop entrepreneurs the true business
owners that are adding
value in our communities that we know
that when we go spend that dollar in
that grocer so that dollar is being
recirculated
in our neighborhood where do we go wrong
where we started rewarding
the businesses that are extracting the
dollar as much as our
of our community um the to change stores
to reach
the big box stores amazon that's not
adding value back to our community
but we made a conscious decision to do
that we we
stripped away antitrust laws starting in
and unleashed private capital
investments and growth without any more
regulations and checks so we made a
conscious decision that we in order to
catch up to the rest of the world
we need to we need private capital to be
leveraged
and to grow and to drive our innovation
since 1980
but what happened is when you award
money money
monopolistic growth the smaller guys
smaller businesses get hurt we can't
have big business and protect small
business at the same time
so now my goal as a policy maker
is to try to come back and figure out
how do we reprioritize the local
economies how do we make our economies
more resilient so every time when we
have these downturns and
and and economic uh downturns
it's not just the big guys that are
getting all the subsidies and all the
tax credits and they're actually getting
wealthier doing these downturns while
all the smaller businesses
are going bankrupt that hurt so that's
kind of the space that i'm
in yeah but i'm all i'm uh but be you
being a much
in-depth business person an entrepreneur
i'm always open to
you know people's advice you know and
how do we is there a balance do you
think well let's let's go back let's do
this let me i mean the biggest thing is
you you know
one of the things i the fact what you
just said to me right now everything
changed with my lens and you
you know uh uh you know when your
parents lost that grocery store how
painful was it for your mom and dad and
yourself how difficult was it
yeah i mean i had a long at a very young
age i learned about
debt and how debt works and
how psychologically damaging it is for
immigrants dealing with
financial stress so yeah was there a lot
of pressure in the family like did you
see a lot of pressure from that
yeah yeah i still remember the day when
we shut down that store my dad and i
yeah he brought me into the grocery
store and he brought a slash hammer i
had a bat and he just
guys brought me in shut down the store
and he was just like smashing
all the goods and all the equipment and
i had no idea
why we spent two hours doing that and i
realized
much later on there's nothing he could
have done um
the landlord increased that rent you
know the space by like 800 percent
expanded the back that we couldn't use
uh
all the government agencies wouldn't do
anything to help us there was no one no
council member no elected official
would would step in we didn't know
anyone but for an immigrant
you know when you had everything in line
you give up
all you had um from your homeland to
come here
to as you know to pursue that dream and
is to see it go away and you don't you
feel
powerless and you feel voiceless there's
nothing you could do is pick up a slash
hammer
and start just smashing your own
products and that would that left a very
indelible mark i bet
um in my mind i bet you know it's it's
so crazy
uh i know you're a true believer i know
aoc is a true believer
a lot of politicians are now true
believers you know that i know that both
on the left and the right some of them
it's more career
lawyer i want to move up and listen
there's nothing wrong with one in that
kind of recognition
but i know and respect when someone
is a true believer uh uh
versus just hey saying what i know aoc
is a true believer i know you're a true
believer
i think sometimes you know i have three
kids and one on the way
sometimes i think yesterday we're out
there we're looking at a home and my
realtor
this one lady starts panicking it's like
oh my god oh my gosh please don't let
them do that don't let them do that
don't let them do that i'm like
so my kids are why you know how my kids
are they're walking by the pool
and then it's the inner coastal so
there's the stairs to go
down to stand up on the jet ski and if
they fall they're going to fall on the
intercoastal and they're going down and
tim's like no no no
don't let them i said listen if i tell
them not to do it
they're going to do attention so the
moment we walk inside they're going to
be in there they're doing it in front of
me it's okay let them do it
and i says you know what he says i like
the fact that you allow your kids
to go you know and you know have a
little bit of freedom with themselves
you know what i thought about i thought
about i was raised in a in an
environment where it was so controlling
you know sometimes parents think they're
doing the right thing for the kids
but then you don't see the negative side
effects what 50 years later you know
what i'm saying
and i think sometimes politicians do
that i really think
aoc yourself sanders i
really think i'll give you the ted cruz
i'll
i really think even the people on the
far right the far
i really think they think they're doing
the right thing okay
the right thing but sometimes like for
example when the whole minimum wage
conversation came about right the 15
minimum wage okay you know uh uh
i'm i'm in the small business community
so i'm always dealing with small
business owners and i consult for them i
sit on boards and i run multiple
companies and etc etc
when the conversation about small
business owners would come up with 15
minimum wage and i would talk to
somebody that has 17
employees in you know oklahoma city or
you know
a small business not a thousand
employees not 517 employees eight
employees nine employees kind of like
your dad
the fifteen dollar minimum wage may hate
may help
the person making 10 bucks going to 15
bucks sure
but the 15 an hour minimum wage proposal
that bernie sanders went after bezos and
bezos said what
we have made a decision at amazon we are
not going to be paying anybody less than
an hour and everybody was like
wow what a noble thing you did jeff
bezos
he can afford 15 bucks an hour so bernie
sanders
trying to help the low-income families
you know that are making less than 15 he
indirectly
helped amazon you know that policy that
i know he's trying to help
it help amazon then the small business
owner that he was trying to help is like
dude i can't pay 15 bucks an hour to a
16 year old kid that's my
best friend's daughter he asked me to
put her job and she's just doing bad i
can't pay her 15 bucks and
it's 50 more than what i pay my profits
i'm going out of business so
you know the the it goes back to the
parenting part where you know half the
time parenting is about not screwing up
screwing the kids up too much i think
sometimes some of the policies from the
left and far left socialist
it's noble but man does it have
long-term side effects it's going to be
painful and
the people that we're trying to help
initially are the ones that end up
paying a big price 5 10 15 years later
what are your thoughts about that i i've
seen some of your other clubs about
fixing um your creative ways of
addressing some of the tax
injustice of people making fifty
thousand dollars or less
or you know should be taxed at zero
percent then that would equate to people
making hundred thousand dollars
and you go from there so i think your
intent
um the way that i'm hearing you is
actually aligned with
many of the left or the socialist
uh trying to get resolve a common
problem which is
like you said new york america
immigrants come here to make the
impossible happen
right we want to know that when we come
here
with nothing in our pockets that if i
work hard enough if i'm an immigrant
i look at you patrick and you are a
successful businessman but hey
one day if i work hard enough i can be
wealthier than you just be based on my
pure hard work
i want to believe that right now more
immigrants
waking up and realizing the system no
matter how hard i work now
i could never beat patrick see i don't
believe that i
see but that's what i'm telling you as
as an elected official
on the ground feeling the tensions
between communities hearing everyday
immigrants
suffering that's how what that's what
they're saying that's how they're giving
up
fundamental hope and i'm saying that is
why
i think for you when your position
uh for people who are in finance we all
have a collective responsibility
because if if the working class people
start
opting out saying this game is rigged it
like it is it's not
gonna it's not rewarding hardware yeah
you know no matter what i do
people who were born on third base
continue to win
if we keep saying that then you make it
true you know hitler said
uh if i tell a lie to myself long enough
i start believing it right if you tell a
lie
enough times people start by the way i'm
not calling anybody a liar and
what a person to quote you know i'm not
quoting anybody to make any kind of
comparison all i'm saying is you know
i grew up one day my dad and i got into
the biggest argument and here's what the
argument was my parents got a divorce
are your parents still together are your
parents
okay my and by the way i had a lot of
korean friends growing up
i don't have one bad memory about
koreans i will tell you some of them are
quiet but they can fight
there was this one korean was a quiet
guy but anytime there was a fight he had
this one kick he destroyed big guys with
his kick
so anytime i see koreans i try to have a
civil conversation with them i don't
want to get that kid coming out of
nowhere
but don't worry i'm not a violent person
no no obviously i'm enjoying the
conversation we're having
but you know one day my dad and i were
sitting down in my in
our apartment in granada hills and him
and my wife got him and my mom
got a divorce ugly divorce wasn't pretty
they got divorced twice in 20 years not
a pretty sight they should never got
married but thank god they did
because i'm able to do the interview
here with you but he said you know
all women are this all women all
women all women and one day i just
lost it i said dad stop it
oh my gosh stop telling me all
women are this i said do you want me to
believe that
i said so let me ask you a question do
you want me to believe that and i get
married and i also get a divorce and i
do you want me to do that and i said
then stop telling your son that over and
over again
he's starting to believe it i don't want
to hear it anymore
and it was a heated moment between
father and son and we've had a lot of
good conversations together
he didn't talk to me that night next
night i come and
we're sitting and watching the laker
again he sits there he says i just want
you know you're right
i said what do you mean he says all
women are not like that i just had a bad
experience
and i don't want you to believe it i
said i appreciate that dad i just i just
don't think we need to say that kind of
stuff over and over again because god
forbid my kid starts believing it i
don't want them to believe it
so i think if we say you know
people immigrants are feeling like right
now the opportunity's not there
if a thousand people with power like you
you got power i mean you're not a you're
somebody that in the future could be the
governor in the state you're a part of
you're a rising star that's coming up
you're not just anybody
you got a very big upside in your career
right very big upside in your career
if we don't speak about the dreaming
part and dreaming i don't mean
social looking obama was a democrat he
got up and he said
he talked about the dream you know this
weekend i was listening to mlk's speech
was about dream
reagan was dream this is not about
republican democrat it's about believing
that the dream is still possible
i don't know if i believe that thing is
gone
or not uh where it was before even
buffett yesterday you know last week
said
america is still the greatest place the
greatest country to live in
you know and i think if we get away from
people dreaming again we have bigger
problems coming up in the future
right i'm saying
my job as a lawmaker is not to be the
salesperson
to sell the dream is to tell the truth
about policies that are failing the
dream
and not enough politicians have done
that part
we have plenty and pastor you can get
so many other politicians on your show
they can talk about the american dream
and feeling and selling the hope
um i'm i'm not part of that club and
and i'm not going to apologize uh for
telling what i see on the ground
because i do care about the dream my
parents sacrificed
everything to come here believing in
that dream
i want to revive that dream so but if i
can't be honest i'm not saying comment
come and destroy every
corporate wall street i'm not i have
plenty of friends
and i i i was one step away from joining
goldman
you know the summer and the dream summer
analyst job i played football i was in
the right fraternity
i did everything that i had to do to end
up in wall street
and i had plenty of friends who went to
lehman and and
goldman so that's my background so i'm
surrounded by them
you know i have these kind of
discussions with them around dinner
tables all the time
but my role is to make sure that the
public sector
is in a better place to revive that
train we need to invest
in base very basic things education
health healthcare housing
and to make sure that our basic human
needs people's human needs are met
instead of saying here's an opportunity
is the door to opportunity
if you can't get there that's on you
forget the lack of housing forget
the horrible conditions social
conditions you're living in we're not
we're no longer going to invest in that
it's up to you to figure out how to get
to that door and many people are not
getting to that door
and while i'm many politicians are
saying i'm giving you that door in front
of you
um so it's up to you to get there
yeah i mean i want to buy that man i
really want to buy we got 10 minutes
left you know i'll wrap it up with this
topic and then we'll finish it off
is amazon okay amazon was coming to new
york and they were
gonna get uh you know the numbers better
than i do three billion dollars over a
10-year period
you know whatever the timeline was and
in return the investment would have
brought back
roughly 27 billion dollars into the city
and bezos went back and forth i think
you were the first public
i think you were the first to come out
and kind of uh uh
not support the movement a matter of
fact i think even campaign behind that i
it may have been there was a name behind
the campaign
and uh uh people over corporate people
over corporate something like that i
don't know what the campaign was about
and then aoc came out and was pretty
vocal about it and then
de blasio said yes and then he changed
his mind cuomo's like what are we doing
so looking back now do you think it was
a right move to push amazon out
instead of bringing those 25 000 jobs at
an average salary of 150 into new york
if you look at the history of these
mega deals including elon tusk and
buffalo
to minnesota i forgot the taiwanese
company that
cut that deal and if you go back and
audit what they deliver they never
deliver and keep up the promises and
even without the subsidies amazon
already did bring close to seven
thousand eight thousand jobs without any
subsidies
of since after that year into manhattan
and other parts of the borough
and they will continue to bring jobs
because their main competitors
are already here microsoft google um
finance as you know
the financial sector as they're
shrinking a little by little every year
the tech sector is growing in new york
um on its own
but with that you like that do you think
that's good do you like that
i think i think as the tech sector is
growing
we also need to make space for local
entrepreneurs i know that we are
putting money behind some of the state
universities to create hubs
to make sure that some of the local uh
entrepreneur types that are doing
positive work
uh for local economies they're trying to
create space for them
so we so we are striking i believe the
right balance
right now um but i have nothing against
if
google wants to bring their jobs here if
they're not
asking for a dime and they want to
invest
their time and effort and trying to
recruit people in new york
that's a good thing we have the talent
we have people that are still here
young tech entrepreneurs who are coding
who are coders
um and so the companies tend to go to
telling us so i know there's it's still
intrinsic value but imagine if we have a
subway imagine if you have the museums
imagine if you have all the
all the intangible things that people
are drawn to
that is the public sector value that we
can create to
draw the people and the talent and the
companies will naturally follow which
amazon
is already doing um as far as like
other parts of new york like buffalo we
and when we analyze numbers we spend
about 1.25
million dollars per one job in in in
elon musk's project in upstate new york
that is
beyond crazy uh we should put a cap
uh if we want to continue economic
development projects we should have a
cap
on how much money we want to spend per
one job to make
safeguard companies like amazon from
extracting tax
you know credits and taxpayers money and
also have clawback clauses
meaning in five years six years if
you're not mis if you're not meeting the
goals
we will claw back uh some of those um
credits and tax breaks so that's a level
of accountability we should put into
every type of mega deal which the
governor
and the mayor did not have uh this was
just the handshake and saying hey
you know you get this if you come here
and that's not good enough
in a perfect world would you like to see
the amount of billionaires in new york
city decrease
in a perfect world i don't think we
should have
uh that much concentrated wealth um we
you know and new york as we mentioned
before is still the wealthiest state
but we are the worst in upper social
mobility at the same time
um that's a fact that's a statistical
fact meaning
like you know you and i disagree on this
but people are
no matter how hard they're working right
now there is no upper social mobility
and that is a direct result of the
extreme
concentration of power and wealth at the
top
so you know moving forward there is a
duty
especially at a time in a crisis there's
never been a time in
american history when we had a social
health economic crisis
when the people at the very top one
percent the five percent
didn't pay their fair share uh to take
care of the rest of society
the top one to five percent have
made much more money during this period
while the rest of us are suffering
and at minimum what we're asking for our
constituents
is to share the burden together so the
wealth
tax of elizabeth warren is something you
support you you like the wealth tax
we have our own version of a new york
wealth tax
which goes beyond property tax because
right now our tax codes are entirely
based on property real property
but it's it's it's been very difficult
to codify and capture
real wealth in the forms of stock
transfers
and a number of different intangible
things capital assets
that why irs traditionally had a hard
time
tracking but in the last 10 years
they've added more mechanisms to keep
track of inflation and how those capital
assets are
uh drawing income people are drawing
income from these capital assets in a
much more accurate way
so i believe if there's a will we can
look at what real world tax looks like
versus just relying on real property tax
which at that point that means we
are relying more on the middle upper
middle class americans to carry the
burden of
a wealth tax if we just rely on real
property tax
so i'll give you the final uh you know
awards here
tell us how you envision the future does
the future look bright
or does the future look scary
uh those i i the future does look bright
okay good there you go i believe you've
got optimism
there's millions millionaires in new
york you know
also trying to get tax justice they're
you know you're talking about
you're i mean you are a very wealthy
businessman and you're talking about not
taxing people 50 000
i mean that is insane like for you to
like come to that company do you think
that's a bad idea
no no that's a good no that's that's
that's amazing you know why i like that
idea here's why i like that idea
you know why i like that idea i like
that idea because because the burden
doesn't go on the small business owner
and burton doesn't go on the employee
why are we taxing people less than 50k
anyways just let them keep a hundred
percent
and then we can put a flat tax above it
i know you would want progressive but we
could put a flat tax above it
but uh allow more people to keep it but
go ahead keep going
your final thoughts about the future and
how you see things working out so i
think the more we have these discussions
and and respectful discussions obviously
you and i differ different sort of
policies
but i believe we can draw come to a
consensus because capitalists and
socialists
and republicans democrats conserve we
all have the same goal which is
to reward hard work that's all we want
like we want people to feel understand
that if they put in the time and effort
that they have
upper mobility it's a very simple
formula what the american dream is
and we can if we all put our heads
together we can get to that better place
as long as we don't have authoritative
demagogic politicians
like trump and cuomo they come from the
same club
you know they they're about control and
they're about abuse of
abusing power as long as we have
collaborative
uh politicians who can see the world as
a win-win world
doesn't have to be a win-lose you're in
the business of win those
i understand that but public servants
should create a world of win-win
uh where it's not winner-take-all
economics
um and as long as we can find that
balance i do feel
very optimistic we can get to a better
place very soon
you know it's crazy the most money i
ever made is deals that i did that would
win win
most money i ever made were deals that i
did would win win at the beginning the
20 year old pat would be win lose
yeah but as i matured and i made a ton
of mistakes as an amateur i realized the
biggest money-making
opportunities are when there's a win-win
because more people want to see you win
as well
so essentially your investment is also
protected
more than anything else ron i so enjoyed
this conversation
because uh you know opposing
philosophies
some areas we have similar philosophies
in but uh we
share one thing we believe in america we
believe america is a
great country and we want to make it
better and i appreciate you coming on
and being a guest on valuetainment
thank you so much patrick thank you
buddy take care so two similar stories
here ron comes here from korea i come
here from iran we're about the same age
one year apart
my kids uh sometimes interrupt me on a
zoom so that's his you know
he goes into politics i go into business
later on we believe in a different dream
a different american dream
he thinks currently times are
challenging
where somebody doesn't believe that it's
possible for one day somebody to become
extremely
successful i believe what do you think
comment below
i want to hear your thoughts and i did a
a similar type of a conversation and
banter i had with
richard wolff professor he is uh
probably forbes says the most respected
reputable socialist professor in america
and we had a good debate together about
socialism and capitalism
if you've never watched it click over
here to watch it with that being said
have a great day everybody take care bye
[Music]